it has been an absolutely joyful
rewarding challenging fascinating and
occasionally bumpy ride and I wouldn't
change a thing a Trailblazer for women
in journalism when Barbara Walters
started out at NBC in the early 1960s
women struggled to be taken seriously in
The Newsroom
but in the years that followed she built
her name as one of the most revered
figures in American journalism when
women tell me that they entered the
field of Journalism I went to school to
study it because that's my legacy that
makes me very proud and that's the last
thing
there weren't these women when I began
and I'm so glad if I could Inspire
anyone Walters made headlines herself in
1976 when she became America's first
female Network news anchor it came with
then unprecedented one million dollar
salary but if you were in charge of the
defense did it just get away from you
what happened already a household name
her hard-hitting interviews with
presidents royalty and pop culture icons
solidified her place as a star in the
world of news
Walters became a fixture at NBC for the
next four decades
as her stature grew she blurred lines
between journalists and celebrity well
it's very exciting and throwing
throw it crazy I mean to be a star you
know when you're in the news Department
you're not considered a star you're
considered a very serious journalist at
least you hope you are so I mean this is
my claim to immortality
Walters received countless awards for
her work including a Peabody and 12
Emmys
in her later career she continued to
break new ground with her daytime pal
show The View
the old-female chat show proved an
unexpected hit a testament to her
continued appeal and her capacity for
reinvention I hope that I will be
remembered as a good and courageous
journalist I hope that some of my
interviews
not created history but
were witness to history although I know
that title has been used
and I I think that when I look at what I
have done I have a great sense of
accomplishment I don't want to sound you
know proud and haughty but I think I've
had good
just a wonderful career